i've got this 2x2 matrix a here and i've
got this other member of r2 this vector
b
let's figure out all of the interesting
things that we can figure out about this
matrix and this vector so the first
thing of interest and this is all going
to essentially help us visualize what we
learned in the last video is the null
space of a
the null space of a
so to figure out the null space of a we
can just we know that the null space of
a is equal to
the null space of the reduced row
echelon form of a
so let's just find out the reduced row
if we
let's say we leave the first row the
same we get three minus two and let's
replace the second row with the second
row minus two times the first so six
minus two times three is zero and minus
four minus two times minus one is zero
and then let's replace the first row
with the first row divided by three so
then that becomes 1 minus 2 3 and the
second row is still 0. so that's the
reduced row echelon form of a
and we want to find its null space so we
want to find all of the vectors that we
can multiply it by so this is a vector
x1 x2
that is equal to the zero vector in r2
so the second row gives us no
information 0 times x1 plus 0 times x2
is equal to 0. no information there so
our only constraint is the first row 1
times x1 let me write it here so 1 times
x1
plus let me write it this way minus 2
thirds times x2
minus 2 3 times x2
is equal to that 0
is equal to that 0 right there or we
could write that
x 1 is equal to 2 3
x 2.
so if we wanted to write the null space
the null space
of a
and let me just make a let me actually
before i write that just to simplify
things and just to show you that things
can you know that x2 isn't some special
number let's just say that t let's just
say that x two is equal to t where t is
some
real number and then we would have x one
x one is equal to two thirds
is equal to two thirds times t
so the null space of our matrix the null
space of a is going to be equal to the
set of all
x1 x2s
that are equal to
that are equal to some
some real number t times the vector
times the vector let's see we have a
x two is equal to t times one
and x one is equal to two thirds t
so two thirds one
just like that that is our null space
all of the all of the
comb all of the multiples of the vector
two thirds one and actually just to make
this a little bit simpler we can pick c
let's let's pick t sorry let's pick t to
be equal to 3c
so then what you have if this is equal
to 3c if you multiply the 3 times these
we could rewrite this as being equal to
equal to the x1s
x2s that are equal to the scalar c where
that's some other real number
times
three times two-thirds is
two
three times one is three
and the whole reason why i did that is
just to have write the null space with a
slightly simpler basis vector the one
that doesn't have any fractions in it
so we or we could also write the null
space is equal to the span
the span of the vector
3. all of these statements are
equivalent so we figured out the null
space maybe another interesting thing
especially if we're going to make this
relate to what we did in the last video
is find the solution set to the equation
ax is equal to b
to do that we just set up an augmented
matrix so we set up an augmented matrix
minus 2
6 minus 4 and we augment it with b
9 18
and then we put the left hand side in
reduced row echelon form
and we get let's keep the first row the
same we get three
minus two
and then nine let's replace the second
row with the second row minus two times
the first
so we get six minus two times three is
zero
minus four minus two times minus two
well that's zero as well right minus
four plus four
eighteen minus two times nine that's
eighteen minus eighteen that's also 0
almost there now let's just replace the
first row with the first row divided by
3.
so the second row is going to stay the
same
and the first row is going to be 1
minus 2 3
minus two-thirds and then we get a three
there
so we can write
so if we wanted to rewrite this as a
kind of an equation we would write that
the matrix one minus 2 3
0 0
times the vector that's in our solution
set x 1 x 2 is equal to
the vector 3 0.
or another way to say it the second row
gives us no real constraint so we don't
have to pay attention to it the first
row tells us that x1
minus two-thirds times x2 is equal to
is equal to three or
that x1 is equal to 3 plus 2 thirds
x2 let's do the same exercise here we
could say that
if we say that x2
is equal to t
then x1 is equal to three plus two
thirds t or we could say that the
solution set
the solution set to ax is equal to b
is equal to the set
of all
x1 x2s
that are equal to let's see x1 is equal
to a three
plus two-thirds so plus t times two
thirds
let's write it like that
it's a plus right there
and x2 is just equal to t so it's just
equal 1 times t plus well let's just say
zero
so that's our solution set right there
and you might immediately recognize that
it's it's some particular solution plus
some scaled-up version of our null space
right there that's our solution set i
could do that same substitution that we
did over here i could say that
let's replace t with
three c
and so we could rewrite this as being
equal to
is equal to let's rewrite it neatly x1
x2
is equal to
is equal to the vector i want to run a
space three zero
plus c times let me scroll over a little
bit
plus c times
the vector three times two thirds is two
three times one is 3.
so it's equal to the vector 3 0 plus
some member of our null space right the
null space was a span of 2 3 or all the
scalar multiples of our null space and
this is where c is any real number so
that's our solution set that's our null
space now one other thing that might be
of interest just because it's the
orthogonal complement to the null space
and this relates to what we were doing
in the last video is what the row space
of a is
so the row space of a is just the column
space of a transpose
this is the row space
this is the row space of a and what is
this equal to this is equal to the span
the span of the row vectors of a so we
have three minus two
so we have three minus two
and we have
six minus four
six
minus four
but this guy is just two times that
vector right there so we could just
ignore it so it's just the span
it's just the span of the vector
three
minus two
now let's graph all of these so we have
the row space we have the solution set
and we have the null space
let's see if we can graph it
we can make a
reasonable graph of this thing right
here
so i have
my vertical axis right there
i have my
horizontal axis right there
now what does
the null space look like it's all the
multiples of 2 3
so if i go out 1 2 and then i go up 1 2
3 the vector 2 3 looks like this in a
standard position
and the null space is all of the
multiples of this
so all the multiples of that so if you
do all of the multiples of that you get
a line that looks something like this
if you do all the multiples of that
vector you get a bunch of vectors that
point to every point on this green line
right there so that right there
is the null space of a
now what is the solution set the
solution set is the vector three zero
so it is the vector three zero so one
two three
so it is the vector three zero
plus
plus members of the null space so if you
take any of these let's say if you add 2
3 2 3 would look like this
but you're adding any multiple of 2 3.
so when you add multiple all the
different multiples of 2 3 you get this
line right here it's shifted essentially
by that vector 3 0.
so this right here
is the solution set so solution
to
a x is equal to
b that's the solution set right there
now what's our row space the row space
is all of the multiples of the vector 3
minus 2.
so what does 3 minus 2 look like the
vector 3 minus 2 we go 1 2 3 and then we
go down 2. so you go
you go 1 2
and it's going to look like this
it's going to look something like this
and then if we were to graph it
we were to graph it and you could see
well
it's going to look something like i want
to do relatively neatly
so it's going to look something like
this let me do another color actually
it's going to look like that
right
i can't do it at all straight let me do
it a little bit
now this is horrible
something about the bottom right hand
side of my
uh that's a pretty decent attempt
so that right there
that right there is my row space
is my row space because if you have 3
minus 2 you get roughly to that point
and then you want all of the multiples
all of the multiples of that vector
right 3 minus 2. if you multiplied it by
minus 1 you would get the vector minus 3
2 so it would look like this
it would be minus 3 2 it looked like
this mine 2 3 and then up 2 would be
like that so all the scalar multiples of
that as well that is our column space
and notice sorry that is our row space
and notice that our row space is
orthogonal to our null space
it is our orthogonal to our null space
now this is a nice visual representation
of everything that we've everything we
can do essentially with this matrix
right here which is our matrix a
but in the last video we had a very
interesting result
we had a very interesting result we said
that if we have some b let me do it in a
new color we found out that if we had
some b that is a member of the column
space of a
then
the solution with the smallest length or
we could say the smallest or the
shortest
the shortest
solution
to
a x is equal to b
is a unique
is a unique member
is a unique member of
of the row space
of the row space of a now let's see this
is what we this is our big takeaway from
the last video and it might have seemed
a little hard to visualize before but
now that we've graphed it all out i
think we can visualize it this blue line
right here is a solution set
the row space right here
is this line that's perpendicular to the
solution set but notice one of the
vectors on it
one of the vectors on it
is both
pointing to something pointing to a
position on the solution set and it is
in my row space this vector right here
that i'm doing in a bold green
that vector right there we could call
that vector r
because that vector is both a member of
my row space right it points it points
if you view it as a position vector it
points to a point on the line that
represents our row space all of the
members of our row space point to points
on this line but at the same time it
also points to a point right there that
is a member of our solution set and
notice it is the only vector in our row
space that points to a point that is a
member of our solution set and if you
just look at it from a geometric point
of view all of the other solutions
all of the other solutions point to all
of the other points on that line so
that's one of the solutions let me write
that's a solution right there
this is a solution right there
that is a solution right there all of
the vectors that point to
point to things on this solution line
right there there's all solutions but
the very shortest one is this green one
this green one is essentially orthogonal
to it because it's a member of the row
space and this is essentially has the
same slope as our null space it's
orthogonal so it's kind of the shortest
path distance to getting to our solution
set
and if for this exact example if we
wanted to we can actually figure out
what this shortest vector r is
we've got the vector 3 0 over here right
the vector 3 0 is this vector right here
so if you take 3 0
minus your vector so let me say r let me
write it this way our vector r the
special shortest solution
is going to be a member of our column
space our column space is a span of 3
minus 2. so it's going to be equal to
some scalar multiple
of 3
minus 2.
now we know that 3 0 points to another
solution on our on our solution set but
we know that if we take the difference
of these two vectors if i take 3 0 if i
take the vector 3 0
and from that i subtract the vector r
what do i get i get this vector right
there let me do that in another color
i get
this pink vector right there that pink
vector it's not in a standard position
but that pink vector is going to be a
member of our null space
that pink vector is going to be a member
of our null space so if i take 3 0 that
minus my r so minus
c times
3 minus 2
right that's going to be this pink
vector right there
so if i were to take the dot product so
this vector right here let me make this
clear that vector is this pink vector
right there
that's in my null space i could shift it
over right it's not a standard position
there but if i do the standard position
it shows it points to something on my
null space line so that's in my null
space so if i were to dot it with any
member of my row space is going to be
equal to zero the row space is the
orthogonal complement of the null space
so let me take the dot product of that
with some member of my row space might
as well just take the basis vector for
my row space that's a member of my row
space so if i dot it with three
sorry i don't shouldn't write that as a
fraction three
minus two if i dot it with three minus
two that will be equal to zero so let's
see if we can solve
for c
so we get let's see if we do this we get
this inside part this pink vector right
there is going to be 3 minus 3c right 3
minus 3c and then you're going to have 0
minus
minus 2c so that's just 2c
so that's
so this part right here just simplifies
to that i just perform the scalar
multiplication and then the subtraction
and then if we dot that
with my basis vector for my row space
three minus two
this should be equal to zero so what do
we get we get three times three which is
nine
minus let me see three times 3
minus
minus 3
or minus 3c times minus 2. let me write
this way or like plus
let me write well let me do it this way
this is probably the easiest way to do
it well sorry i was actually doing it
wrong this is the first entry so you
have 3
minus 3c times 3
right 3 minus 3c the first entry times
the first entry here
plus
2c
plus 2c
times
is equal to 0. i was performing that dot
product in a strange way i think i got a
little caught off guard by this two
terms but anyway the first term times
the first term plus the second term
times the second term that's what our
dot product is this isn't a matrix this
is just the first and the second term
right there
so then what do we have here
we have
3 times 3 is 9
minus 9c
minus 4c
minus 4c is equal to 0. if we add the
well this is 9 minus 13 c is equal to 0
or we get
13 let's see 9 is equal to 13c or c is
equal to 9 over 13.
so just like that we've solved for our
special vector r we said hey look if you
take
this 3 0 vector and the difference
between that and our vector r you're
going to get some vector
right here that is in our null space and
if you take the dot product of that
with some member in our row space you're
going to get 0 and the dot product is
that entry times that entry plus that
entry times that entry and so you get
c is equal to 9 over 13. so our special
vector
r
the unique shortest solution to the so
to the equation ax is equal to 0 is
9 over 13
times the vector times our basis vector
3 minus 2
or we could write that as 20
27 over 13 right and then we have
3 times 9 and then 2 times 9 is
minus 18
over 13.
and that right there is our shortest
basis or our shortest basis the shortest
vector in our row space that satisfies
this equation let me write it better if
the it's the member the unique member of
our row space that also happens to be
the shortest solution to ax is equal to
b so this is an example of what we
talked about in the last video and
hopefully you see visually why this is
so